let's talk about the war in syria
entire cities flattened
hospitals bombed ancient sites blown up
13 million people forced to leave their
homes
at one point the u.n said the
battlefield chaos made it impossible to
count the dead
so they stopped but the fighting hasn't
and people are still dying the level of
humanitarian suffering
in syria is just beyond imagination i
think
nobody expected that 10 years later
we would still be in the midst of this
conflict
so who's fighting who where are syria's
millions of refugees
and why does this seem like a war
without end
[Music]
[Applause]
for years the syrian war was the biggest
news story around
today not so much maybe it's media
fatigue
maybe people think it's over and that
president bashar al-assad is one
the syrian government seems to think so
[Music]
cities and railways are being rebuilt
domestic flights have started up again
they're even letting travel vloggers in
i never knew
amazing syria it's not what you think we
have bar
entertainment stuff people are trying to
rebuild
in reality though most of syria is still
in ruins
[Music]
if you compare the amount of investment
to fuel score
compared to the money to alleviate the
impact of this war on
the syrians the people who have bear the
brunt of this crisis
it's very little it all started back in
2011.
the arab spring was happening and
leaders in tunisia and egypt had already
been overthrown in syria
some children had been watching all that
on tv and decided to send their
president
a message
the children were arrested and tortured
and people started protesting
the government responded with force and
the syrian uprising was on
demonstrators killed while clashing with
security forces
in what appears to be the most serious
threat to his family's 40-year rule
protests have now spread from the
southern city of daraa to damascus hama
homs latakia
and other cities the protest movement
was
seismic i mean it shook the regime to
its foundation
the assad regime had been in power for
more than 40 years
starting with bashar's father many
people were tired of things like
corruption
being repressed they wanted allah said
out
when the war started it was very much a
civil war
assad forces against the syrian
opposition that included people who
defected from the military
and opponents who picked up a gun then
other players
piled in the u.s turkey and others sided
with the opposition
pretty much from the start the syrian
president had allies too
russian warplanes bombed from the air
and militias backed by iran
fought on the ground but there were
other enemies common to them all
isil al-nusra front and other groups
consider terrorists
took advantage of the chaos to take
control
then syrian kurdish fighters got
involved they joined up with arab
militias to push
isil out and stake their own territorial
claim
turkey though sees them as terrorists
and didn't want them on its southern
border
so they went to war with the syrian
kurds it's been a messy battlefield
and over the course of those 10 years
the syrian people have suffered the most
[Applause]
[Music]
blockaded starved and detained mainly by
assad forces
victims have filed allegations of war
crimes and courts all over europe
things were bad during the peak of the
war but right now
the economy has never been worse
[Music]
nearly 90 percent of syrians live below
the poverty line
their currency the pound is at its
lowest ever level against the dollar
making everything expensive
there are shortages of fuel food some
places only have electricity for a few
hours a day
add to that a covered 19 epidemic that
no one knows the real scale of
even without the conflict being at a
high level
uh there still aren't services
sufficient
enough for people to have jobs
and send their kids to school and
receive adequate health care
okay so where is the war at right now
these days the government has control of
about two-thirds of the country
but they're still fighting for parts of
the north where all kinds of groups are
still hanging on
some syrian rebels are in one part where
turkey's basically in control
and then there's idlib the last
opposition stronghold
[Music]
it's a complicated place syrian rebels
are mixed in with lots of groups
considered terrorists
millions of refugees are living there in
[Music]
camps
[Music]
and every so often syrian and russian
forces attack
they say they're liberating idlib from
terrorists
meanwhile syrian kurds control this
region
hundreds of u.s soldiers are still there
too mainly protecting oil fields
but there are other groups roaming
around including militias backed by iran
like hezbollah
you'll notice though there's no sign of
isil anywhere it took a while
but eventually they were pushed out
their leader abu bakr al-baghdadi was
killed
by the u.s in 2019 and most of their
fighters were either captured or killed
but isil's ideology has survived and
it's spreading in camps where fighters
and their families are being held
isis builds on several things including
kaios the lack of a state the grievances
the division
the people in need for jobs and isis is
building up on that
they're recruiting so that's where the
conflict is at
but you can't talk about a nation
without talking about its people
and half of the syrian people are
refugees
more than six million are internally
displaced
but another five and a half million are
living outside of syria
turkeys taken in the most followed by
lebanon jordan iraq and egypt
over the years there have been countless
peace talks and all of them have failed
right now the un has put together a
committee made up of both
opposition and government people it's to
try to turn the page on the war by
writing a new constitution but it's not
really working
meanwhile there are all those external
players still using syria to settle
their scores
until we see the externals confront
each other directly rather than on the
syrian ground
i don't see an actual end to the syrian
conflict
there's an argument to be made that this
war really is over that the assad regime
is won
if that's true it's come at an enormous
cost
and 10 years on things in syria have
never been worse
ten years of war in less than 10 minutes
is a big ask
so think of that episode as a primer you
can visit aljazeera.com for more context
and the latest news out of syria i'll
see you next week
you